[Music]
nets are Kobe do want to reveal the
truthful John's known just as he has
promised he would in the very first
season and we know Ned is a man of his
word that's the theory I'm bringing in
this video I know that it might sound
ridiculous at first but there are many
cool skins and evidence supporting his
theory the showrunner decided to reveal
to us Jon Snow true identity in the
season six finale John is not Nan's
bastard betrayed her son of Lyanna stark
and rhaegar targaryen in the season 7
finale on the other hand shall reveal
Joshu name and also finally confirmed
that Jon Snow is in fact illegitimate
son Prince Rhaegar and Lyanna as they
were married and his name is Aegon
Targaryen he's the true heir to the UH
throne and his Danny's nephew
however just still knows nothing and
therefore many fans are wondering how
Valjean learned truth regarding his show
lineage or in other words Whoville will
the truth - Jon Snow at the end of last
season John and Danny are heading to
Winterfell verse 7 brainer waiting for
John to reveal him the truth
salmon brain telling John the truth is
too predictable and too simple to come
true at least in my opinion I definitely
see them trying to reveal to John but
something will most likely get on their
way each time to try for example bran
might have John to have a word with him
in private but then the horn will be
blown the White Walkers are taking
Winterfell interrupting their
conversation I don't expect something
like that to happen so hobble just don't
find out who is she parents really
aren't what his real name is this is
something that John must certainly find
out throughout the final season that's
not questionable but still the question
remains who will reveal the truth to Jon
Snow quite a long time ago I delivered
you're worried about Howland Reed in
which I brought you the possibility of
his appearance in the final season along
with the possibility of him being of a
huge importance in John's life as I
believe that he might be the one to
reveal John's real identity to Jon for
all of you that are wondering how could
how andrey be the chosen one to reveal
the truth of john let me introduce you
to Howland Reed and his importance in
Game of Thrones with a few sentences
Howland Reed is the man whose children
Meera and Jojen played important role in
brain Stark's life
a man who saved it from certain death
save Ned Stark who gave his best but
couldn't stand chance against her are
today in superior fighting skills the
same man loyal vessel House Stark
Howland Reed has played very important
role in star's life by saving Ned from
certain death is playing a very
important role because if not for his
children brain probably would not even
have become the three-eyed Raven he
would have probably been dead and will
doubtlessly play a huge role in the
final season considering that he is
among the few that and the truth about
John's - identity / knows about John's
parentage due to his ability of having
visions of the past and Sam knows it
from the books is red but Howland Reed
was actually there Howland witness
John's birth and
I don't see how Android not appearing in
the final season I definitely see
Howland having an important role in this
huge revelation by just like Sam and
brain I don't see how and revealing to
John either but rather confirming it to
him sure Brent could share what he'd
seen in his vision or Sam could show him
what his red or even Howland Reed could
tell him the truth has he witnessed it
himself but the only way for the
revelation to have its full effect is
for John to discover it on his own
through the most important person in his
life Heather Stark
don't get me wrong literal three-branch
Sam and Hollander least some of them
will definitely play in form role in
this huge revelation as I definitely see
them confirming to John the truth he
will find out where his father Ned Stark
Ned might not be his real father but Ned
will always be John's father he's the
one who raised him he's the one who
saved his life back to the question
having Ned Stark reveal John the truth
the truth that he kept through his whole
life as he promised he will to his dying
sister Lyanna when his dead Bellavia
maternes has taught us anything
throughout his 7 seasons it's the Ned
Stark is man of his word if Ned made
promise he will keep it without a doubt
there's actually this one promise Ned
has yet to fulfill that might be dead
but it doesn't mean that he will not
fulfill his last promise and we do want
to reveal to show the Jon Snow the truth
which would Sam Brennan maybe even
Howard confirm this brings us to the
crypts of interval the place for Ned hid
a hint or clue for John that feel real
to him his true parentage the crypts
have been included in both the books and
the show which along with all the scenes
that took place or Darren show and we
told Jon's dreams and visions about it
in the books has led many people to
believe that there's something about
them of high significance to the
upcoming plot so the net hid a hint for
Jon and will Dwight will find out the
same hidden object that will reel to him
that he's not Ned's bastard but rather
son of Lyanna stark and rhaegar
targaryen
before I focus on a possible object that
Ned might have hidden somewhere in the
crypts let's see what facts would have
even led Ned to hide it below interval
the crypts are massive and the larger
the entire Castle complex about ground
making the perfect spot for something of
a huge importance to hide it as not only
it would be hard to find it but it's
also the last place someone would look
for there are only a few people that are
visiting the crypts which this scene
from season 5 episode 4 is confirming as
you can see while visiting the stark
family crypts beside relighting the
candle sense also picks up the feather
of the floor which is the same fairy
Robert Baratheon placed in the hand of a
statue of Leanna in the very first
episode of the series but as being said
it's easy to see why wouldn't it have
hidden something of a huge importance in
the crypts there's not certainly a high
possibility that net took something
wrong tavarov jaw
something related to the truth about
Zhang's parentage and hid it in the
crypts
but if naturally did hide a hint for
John whether it's records widely popular
Harper Targaryen sword or something
entirely else how is it possible that no
one accidentally came up to it before
well he had it very well one would say
but if he hid it very well how is Yun
supposed to find it out a Song of Ice
and Fire gave us a few hints regarding
this question in the books John has
recurring nightmares about mentoring
around the crypts in the very first
novel in Song of Ice and Fire while at
Castle black Jon Snow tell Sam that he
sometimes dreams of the crypts just says
that he knows he has to go down there so
he walks deeper into the crypts but is
afraid of what he will find within them
and awakens every time when the crypts
become too dark so dreams would most
likely lead John into the crypts now
let's see which objects Ned might have
hidden below interval manifests are
assuming that generally defined are
accessor Blackfyre which are Valyrian
steel swords belonging to House
Targaryen Aegon the conquerer wilted
like fire in battle during the war
conquest while later it was also welded
by many of the more marshal Targaryen
Kings which would soothe chant perfectly
however black fire was later given by
Aegon the unworthy to his bastard son
daemon which eventually removed sword
from House Targaryen possession as Damon
found in his own lineage house Blackfyre
taking the name of the sword the sword
black fire remained in the hands of each
successive generation of house Blackfyre
until the line was wiped out the source
current owner location is unknown but it
most certainly is not hidden in the
crypts of Winterfell as its last known
location was not even Westeros dark
sister on the other hand belonged to
Vizzini Targaryen the sister wife of
Aegon the conquerer the sword was
allegedly lost during the Blackfyre
rebellion a most certainly is near here
and summer in the crypts even though we
might have already seen it in series so
John most certainly will not find a lost
again family sword in crypts of interval
and it will not be an object that will
reel or confirm to Jack his show
parentage
so the question still remains what could
have net hidden in the crypts take into
account that an object is suppose
revealed to John Snow issue parentage
should be regulars well known item
there's a high possibility that Ned
Stark he draggers widely popular harp
and it will eventually confirm to John
his show lineage rakers harp might be
one of if not the only object that
Rhaegar could have left in the Tower of
joy with his beloved wife Lina Stark not
only did Elena enjoy listening rehgar
playing her but he also most likely did
not carry his harp with him while
marching in the war let me also point
out that there has not been any mention
of Rhaegar sharp during or after
Robert's rebellion it might be implying
that Rhaegar beside leaving his best
friend and the greatest fighter the
Seven Kingdoms as
ever seen to protect Liana in their
unborn son wrecker also most likely left
his heart with Liana in the taro joy is
a symbol for Liana of his love towards
her and promised to return however upon
rakers death during the battle the
Trident and upon Diana's death in the
hands of Ned editar oh joy it's possible
that Ned took craigers harp along with
Lina's corpse and hid it somewhere
nearly and a statue in the crypts of
interval if naturally did hide Rhaegar's
harp on the Winterfell with intention
for John to find it someday were exactly
did he hide it as it somewhere nearly in
a statue
I place my bet on a tomb no one knew
existed it's John's own tomb the best
Sir John is not supposed to get a tomb
of his own in the crypts so Ned would
have had one made for John in secret we
know that Ned had his empty tomb already
prepared before his death in fact there
are numerous empty and sealed tombs
repaired for not only Ned but also for
his children in the books John often
dreams of the crypts of interval in
which he sees the statutes of Kings so
mentor watching him as he passes by them
John sees the stone star Kings eyes
following him as they tell him he
doesn't belong there which could imply
that John is in fact already given a
place for his own in the crypts
additionally net has similar dreams of
the crypts as John which could be a hint
that he has angered the old kings of
winter by giving John oh please
even though he's not a stark but rather
a Targaryen I believe that the tomb was
prepared for Johnny the crypts of
interval hidden away in the lower levels
in there it will be razor-sharp in the
crown of winter roses Rhaegar laid on
Nina's lepida tourney at Harrenhal when
he crowned her queen of love and beauty
there might even be a letter written by
Ned Stark in which he states that if
John reads this it means that he's dead
and that he said that genres issue of
this way imagine the chills we'd all get
seeing just me the creeps learning truth
while hearing networks or explaining
everything to John this vennett would
also fulfill the last promise he has
ever given some of you might say that
having a to mate for John with his real
name again Targaryen written on it would
make us such a big risk for it to take
as a soul mates and could have told
everyone about it for all we know that
did not have to take any risk with this
because remember there is no literate
stonemason in case you're wondering
didn't net had to keep John's parentage
a secret as he promised to his sister
the answer is yes Ned was supposed to
keep the secret from the world not from
John Snow which is why he promised to
tell me the truth once they see each
other again
Ned kept his promise to his sister
Lyanna he made John his bastard son
sacrificing his honor and he raised him
as his own net cap Joshua parentage a
secret he did not tell anyone from his
wife Kathleen to King Robert the only
reason I did not tell the truth the
giant self earlier is because he had to
wait for John to
in order to understand things in order
to protect him not only would it be
difficult for him to explain to young
John why he has to keep his shoe
parentage a secret but it would also be
a difficult thing to explain how to
explain to a child that his father is
not his actual father how his aunt is
his mother and his grandfather killed
his other grandfather an uncle while he
also went into the war against his
actual father and grandfather and your
best friend killed his father his
grandfather has also been killed
there's also to explain how his uncle
Viserys and then Danny are exiled in
Essos and almost forgot he also had to
explain to him how he is the true heir
to the armed drone but should forget
about that as your best friend would
have him killed if anyone finds out he's
a Targaryen it's very complicated
all in all Ned Stark is an oath keeper
he's a man of his word and therefore I
believe Ned will fulfill the less
promises given Ned will talk to John
about his matter that will reel the
truth - John's note or a letter that is
sitting in John's secret tune with his
real name written on it there will also
be records arpan leonis crown on winter
roses I might as well be overthinking
and brain or Samuel really to him
instead but it just seems too simple and
too predictable for such a huge
revelation to be revealed to John this
way and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see you in the next one
peace
[Music]